HE'S GOING TO BE MUCH BETTER
TONIGHT SO THE
PUCK OUT.
>> Steve: WITH DIFFICULTY
CONTROLLING THE PUCK AND NOBODY
ALLOWED THE SHORTHANDED
GOAL, POWER PLAYS HERE BROUGHT
GOAL.
S
SPEZZA LATE,
OUTSIDE.
>> Steve: STAY IN THE
START HERE TONIGHT, IN
COMBINAT
INSTEAD, 1-0 MAPLE LEAFS IN THE
EARLYK
ALIVE AND LOOK AT MATTHEWS COME
LEAVES, DRIVES IT BACK, WITH TH
WITH
WAY, CORRAL BY MATTHEWS,  IT IN
MARNER PUT IT IS IN,LOWS, YOU S
GUYS GETT ACROSS, MARNER
CONTROLLED WITH THESMUS SAN BEE
FRONT OF THE NIT THERE, SHOWS ME
THE DEVILS ARE COLLECTED HERE B
SHARANGOVICH, SENDS IT IN DEEP
FOR JACK, HUGHES, PICKS UP THE
DAYS.
ALL-STAR COMING YOURLECTED AND
PARTIAL TWO ON O
VEGAS.
>> Steve: IG EVALUATING,
HOW YOU PLAY IN THE THIRD.
>> Steve: HUGHES WITH A PUCK OU
MID AIR, THAT WAS NICE IN THE
NEUTRAL ZONE AND SNAPS IN AS MO
THEY END UP GETTING THE PUCK
ALONG THE WA
DART BACK THE OTHER WAY.
LAY IT EEL BACK
FOR